what's going on guys so Game of Thrones
Season four is hitting the homestretch
it's been intense am i right
man sometimes I get so worked up that I
forget that these are actors playing
roles plus I don't know the difference
between real and pretend so right now
we're gonna peek behind the Iron Throne
and take a closer look at the cast of
Game of Thrones let's start off with the
biggest heads in Westeros the Lannisters
so they may be super despicable and
hateable on the show but in real life
they're kind of delightful look at this
picture of them on this awesome beach
vacation pretty cool they even find time
to horse around with their mortal
enemies
check out that face on Dinklage you guys
remember Black Hawk down pretty good war
movie that featured like every young
actor in Hollywood
among them was Nikolaj coster-waldau
Jaime Lannister while we're at it I
don't want to forget Jaime's brother
everyone's favorite Lannister Peter
Dinklage now he's got a great body of
work awesome actor all that aside check
out this cool footage of him and his
brother horsing around while he's about
to go on trial for his very life dude
totally knows how to party let's talk
about searcy lannister AKA lena headey
now before she was trying to frame her
brother she was trying to save humanity
she was satyr Akana and Terminator the
Sarah Connor Chronicles lying near [ __ ]
you're building Skynet and here's some
kind of cool Emilia Clarke who looks
nothing like Daenerys Targaryen in real
life is slated to play Sarah Connor in
the upcoming Terminator film - Sarah
Connors in Westeros Searcy and Daenerys
aren't the only ones with Schwarzenegger
connections Charles dance
aka Tywin Lannister he was in last
action hero he played the bad guy you
know with the freaky glass eye Hannibal
Lecter can do the catering for
Rosemary's Baby no sequel for you
let's talk Eddard Stark played by Sean
Bean you know him as the guy that has
died in everything but do you remember
that he was Pierce Brosnan's first Bond
villain in 1995's Goldeneye semester
James no glib remark empathy comeback
oh and spoiler alert he dies in that too
one of my hands-down favorite characters
is Arya Stark the characters played by
Maisie Williams now she's a very young
actress and we couldn't find any acting
stuff from her but we did find maybe the
best vine ever check out her reaction to
the red wedding they did like so did
OMG date my mother and brother a day by
the old gods and the new I declare that
cool as hell let's talk about Aria's
road trip buddy Sandor Clegane the hound
now before Rory McCann was the toughest
burn victim in Westeros he was in Hot
Fuzz playing the best one word character
since Hodor Michael yeah Jon for me
times six mojo yeah now the hounds
brother the mountain has been played by
three different actors but the current
actor playing him half Thor
Julius bjornsen is a competitor in those
ESPN's strongman competitions we've got
another leading time bjornsen this time
we've given bran stark a hard time on
the show before one of our favorite
characters is played by Christian Nair
Oh No before he spent his days ho during
around he was a DJ I've been DJing for
20 years now it's always gonna be a big
part of my life DJ Hodor on the ones and
twos here he is dropping a beat with
Arya Stark at the Game of Thrones party
oh by the way he and bran total bros in
real life no rundown of the stark clan
would be complete without mentioning Kit
Harington here he is giving mad respect
to his brother Robb Stark wearing that
shirt the stark boys roll deep for real
no one puts Jon Snow in his place like
Ygritte played by Rose Leslie now she
may play a lowly dirty wildling on Game
of Thrones but she cleans
nicely by that I mean she played a maid
on Downton Abbey we don't think our
dreams are bound to come true because
because they almost never do let's not
forget about John's BFF Sam check out
John Bradley in a stark Tyrell sandwich
nice work big guy oh and did you know
that Sam's girlfriend Gilly and Gendry
were on the British show skins together
I'm sorry I thought you said how about a
little Dark Knight Game of Thrones
crossover action before he was the
poster child against incest Jack Gleeson
was the cute little kid in Batman Begins
become such a little now keeping up with
this Dark Knight connection Aiden Gillen
who plays Petyr Littlefinger Baelish he
was in the beginning of Dark Knight
Rises don't you remember that if I pull
that off will you die it would be
extremely painful you're a big guy for
you Bane could completely be a game of
Thrones character slap a respirator on
the mountain and your got'em next at
small council table actor Julian Glover
who plays pycelle he was the bad guy in
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade who
drank from the wrong Grail
[Music]
[Applause]
he chose poorly
next around the table Conleth Hill who
plays varus before he was conniving and
double-dealing and scheming in King's
Landing
he was starring in a Woody Allen movie
whatever works with its pear-shaped
dagger used to distinguish between an
apple-shaped behind and pear-shaped and
I'm a big fruit eater Natalie Dormer
plays Margaery Tyrell she is a very
attractive but then she had to go and
marry that weasel King Joffrey she needs
a good man like Captain America your
hero well that you know that that
depends on the definition government of
America are you seeing this they're here
let's talk about her dead King Robert
Baratheon played by the actor mark addy
now before he was dying on a hunting
trip in King's Landing he was shaken
what his mama gave him in The Full Monty
I believe in miracles do you came along
you see I'm telling you if King Robert
had those kind of dance moves he might
still be alive
I don't know how but he might be so what
was the coolest tidbit we just laid out
there did we leave anything out let us
know in the comment section below
the coolest answer you're gonna get a
screen junkies t-shirt and by the way
speaking of screen junkies t-shirts one
of our viewers sent us this masterpiece
he's wearing a screen ducky shirt with
Gus fring Giancarlo Esposito that blows
my mind see dreams do come true and
people get these shirts so leave
comments I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal rod Nick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
everything's just so bland and mediocre
and like romerito movies used to be
great no we used to be younger yeah
that's the other thing we used to be
more critical